.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wieso bist du am Plappern?
Dreh dich bitte um.
(Frau) Hier waren heute Morgen
Wasser und Spucke drin.
(Junge) "Du Nutte ..."
Wer hat das gezeichnet?
- Das ist egal.
* Unverständliches Stimmengewirr *
* Die Lehrerin räuspert sich. *
In der Schule wird nicht geschlagen.
Das weisst du ganz genau.
Hilflos, kraftlos ...
Man denkt ...
"Wie soll das gehen?"
Wenn ich dich so nehme ...
Eigentlich
ist sie mit Herzblut Lehrerin.
Es ist ihr Traumberuf.
Sandra Maître arbeitet seit
über 20 Jahren als Primarlehrerin.
Doch bei dieser Klasse
kommt sie an ihre Grenzen.
Einfach sitzen. Sitzen!
Einfach sitzen.
Warten!
Hier.
Manchmal ist einem danach,
alles hinzuschmeissen.
An einer Schule im Kleinbasel
wollen mir Lehrkräfte Einblick geben
in den modernen Schulalltag.
Während Wochen begleite ich sie
mit meiner Kamera
und erlebe ihren
herausfordernden Alltag.
2011 gab es einen Systemwechsel
in der Schweizer Volksschule.
Kleinklassen, Sonderschulen
und Spezialangebote
gehören seither der Vergangenheit an.
Möglichst alle Kinder
sollen eine Regelschule besuchen,
also integriert werden.
Basel-Stadt
nimmt eine Vorreiterrolle ein
beim sog. integrativen Schulmodell.
Ich habe 18 ...
... Kinder in meiner Klasse,
neun Mädchen und neun Buben.
In der zweiten Klasse von Sandra
Maître gibt es grosse Unterschiede
zwischen den Primarschüler/-innen.
Könnten Sie uns zeigen,
wer in Abklärung für ADHS ist
oder bei wem
ADHS diagnostiziert wurde?
Da haben wir ...
Doch nicht nur Hyperaktivität
ist ein Thema.
Die Schule fördert die Kinder
in verschiedenen Sonderprogrammen.
Etwa Heilpädagogik,
Logopädie,
Psychomotorik
oder hier - orange -
die Begabtenförderung.
Aktuell hat nur ein Kind
kein Sonderprogramm.
Laut der Lehrerin erhält die Klasse
ca. sieben Zusatzstunden gesprochen.
Weitere Massnahmen
habe der Kanton abgelehnt
oder die Eltern der Kinder
seien dagegen.
Die Schere zwischen den Kindern
geht weit auseinander -
von Kindern,
die sehr lernschwach sind,
bis hin zu Kindern,
die Begabtenförderung erhalten.
Das Problem ist,
dass ich nicht alles abdecken kann.
Ich kann mich nicht teilen.
Ich möchte gerne jedem Kind
die notwendige Unterstützung bieten,
aber das ist nicht machbar,
denn es sind 18 Kinder.
Und hier sieht man, wie viele von
ihnen mehr Unterstützung bräuchten.
Und die Schulen möchten ja
Integration und Inklusion,
doch alleine
kann ich das nicht leisten.
Inzwischen ist der Hilferuf
ganz oben angekommen:
im Erziehungsdepartement des Kantons.
Wenn man am Schulsystem
etwas verändert,
dann arbeitet man sozusagen
am lebenden Objekt -
man macht etwas,
das Generationen beeinflussen kann.
Deshalb braucht es Sorgfalt
und somit auch Zeit.
Doch Lehrerin Maître
kann nicht mehr warten.
Bereits im vergangenen Schuljahr
informierte sie die Schulleitung
über die Schwierigkeiten.
"So mache ich das nicht mehr."
"Ich brauche jetzt Unterstützung."
Die Primarschulen Thomas Platter
und Wettstein liegen im Kleinbasel.
Einst ein ArbeiterÐ
und Einwandererviertel
auf der rechten Seite des Rheins.
Heute ist es v.a.
ein Ort der Gegensätze,
ein besonders
multikultureller Stadtteil.
Kinder von wohlhabenden Akademikern,
Kinder von Flüchtlingen
und der Nachwuchs
gutbürgerlicher Familien Ð
sie alle treffen sich
im selben Schulhaus.
2022 hat die Lehrerschaft
beim Bildungsdepartement des Kantons
Basel-Stadt eine Initiative
für Förderklassen eingereicht.
Die Verhandlungen sind im Gange.
Sandra Maître holt ihre Klasse
vom Pausenplatz ab.
Eine Massnahme, weil die Konflikte
im Gang regelmässig eskalieren.
* Unverständliches Stimmengewirr *
Frau Maître,
Jonas hat mich geschlagen.
In der Schule wird nicht geschlagen.
Das weisst du ganz genau.
Die Schulleitung
nimmt Sandra Maîtres Hilferuf ernst.
Sie stellt ihr Paula Pfau zur Seite,
die gerade den Abschluss ihrer
pädagogischen Ausbildung macht.
Ich freue mich auf die Kinder.
Nach dem langen Wochenende bin ich
gespannt, was sie erlebt haben.
Die zwei Frauen
führen die Klasse nun zu zweit.
Nicht alle Kinder
möchten gefilmt werden.
Ein Praktikant hilft zusätzlich mit.
In der Klasse 2B
gibt es ein Begrüssungsritual.
Guten Morgen.
Hast du die Kette selbst gemacht?
- Ja.- Oh, toll!
Guten Morgen.
Die Kinder wählen zwischen Tänzchen,
Umarmung oder Abklatschen.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Warst du im Schwimmbad?
- Ja, hier tut es sehr weh.
Ja, da tut es weh. Aber du hast
eine schöne Sommerfarbe.
Guten Morgen, Albin.
Montagmorgen.
Paula Pfau kontrolliert als Erstes
die Hausaufgaben der 8-Jährigen.
Dabei geht es nicht nur
um Schulbildung, sondern auch darum,
ob die Kinder
z.B. genügend frühstücken.
Was ist denn da passiert?
Ich habe es einmal
in meinem Zimmer gelassen
und als ich duschen war,
hat mein Cousin darin gemalt.
Musst du deine Sachen
vor deinem Cousin beschützen?
Ich habe ihn natürlich angeschrien.
Anschreien musst du ihn nicht,
aber mit ihm sprechen.
Man wird nicht darauf vorbereitet,
wie man die Kinder
bei ihren alltäglichen Themen
unterstützen kann.
Wenn man dann zehn Kinder hat,
die man aufs Frühstück
hinweisen muss ...
Wann überprüft man das und wie?
Wie kann man sicherstellen,
dass alle an die Reihe kommen.
Wie stellt man sicher, dass sich
die anderen nicht langweilen?
Die ganze Organisation -
das ist schon "learning by doing".
Und ich bin froh,
dass sie auch da ist.
Welches Ziel möchtest du?
Jedes Kind arbeitet
mit persönlichem Ziel und Programm.
Doch konzentrieren
können sich längst nicht alle.
(Leise) Wir lesen es noch mal.
* Leise Stimmen im Hintergrund *
* Sandra Maître räuspert sich. *
* Unverständliche Szene *
Wieso bist du am Plappern?
Dreh dich bitte um.
Ja, ich komme zu dir.
Alle arbeiten dort,
wo es ihnen am besten passt.
Draussen im Gang ziehen sich
zwei leistungsstarke Kinder zurück,
auf der Suche nach Ruhe.
Ich springe, du spingst,
er springt, es  ...
Voilà. Und dann machst du es
mit "springen".
Okay?
- Okay.
Und hier muss ich es hinschreiben?
- Nur das Verb.
Denn die Personen
stehen ja da schon.
Okay?
Wie ist das,
hier draussen zu arbeiten?
Besser, denn drinnen ist es lauter.
Hier draussen
kann man sich besser konzentrieren.
Im Klassenzimmer
könnt ihr nicht gut arbeiten?
(Beide) Nein.
Denn da gibt es Kinder,
die manchmal mit uns reden wollen,
und dann müssen wir auch reden.
Und das nervt uns dann.
Im gleichen Primarschulhaus
unterrichtet Markus Harzenmoser.
* Klatschen *
Jessica.
Branda.
Aza.
Er steht kurz vor der Pensionierung,
nach 39 Jahren.
Mit seiner aktuellen Klasse laufe es
gut, doch auch er hat Sorgen.
Es gibt mehr Kinder
ohne Frusttoleranz.
Es gibt mehr Kinder, denen zu Hause
fast zu viel abgenommen wird.
Und wenn sie dann hier etwas machen
müssen, wissen sie nicht, wie,
weil ihnen das sonst
immer jemand abnimmt.
Dabei müssten sie das
eigentlich selbst können.
Die Kinder sind weniger belastbar
und unselbstständig.
Das hat zugenommen und äussert sich
in verschiedenen Verhaltensweisen.
Stimmt.
Hast du herausgefunden,
was falsch war?
Der stimmt noch immer nicht.
Harzenmoser
setzt sich für kleinere Klassen
für schwierige Kinder ein,
für sog. Förderklassen.
Jetzt stimmt es.
Er will die Bedingungen
für die künftige Lehrer-Generation
verbessern.
In den nächsten acht Jahren fehlen
schweizweit Ð gemäss Prognose -
rund 11'000 Lehrkräfte
auf Primarstufe.
Ich habe oft erlebt,
wie Kolleg/-innen
daran gescheitert sind.
Ich habe erlebt,
wie Kinder daran gescheitert sind.
Es gehört zu meinem Job,
mich für diese einzusetzen.
Bedeutet das das Ende
der integrativen Schule?
Nein, das finde ich nicht,
denn es gibt genügend andere
integrierte Kinder.
Aber die psychisch vernarbten
Kinder, wie ich sie nenne,
sollten meiner Meinung nach
die Chance erhalten,
zuerst anderswo
zur Ruhe zu kommen.
Sobald das funktioniert,
können sie wieder zurück
in eine grosse Klasse, problemlos.
Cool. Mit Tinte darüber.
Nimm die Tinte.
Darf ich sie bei dir vorbeischicken,
damit du ihnen erklärst,
wie du das gelöst hast?- Ja.
Und das kannst du bitte
noch Louis bringen.
Trotz seiner Erfahrung
ist auch er immer wieder gefordert.
Ein Kind flippt aus.
* Unverständliche verärgerte Rufe *
Ich warte auf dich.
Er ist ausgetickt,
hat geschrien und geschimpft.
Ich weiss nicht, was los war.
Die Pausenaufsicht
hat ihn hineingebracht.
Und ...
Ich habe dann mit ihm gesprochen,
jetzt ist alles wieder gut.
Jetzt wird er hoffentlich reinkommen
und dann ...
Gehst du ins Zimmer, um zu zeichnen?
- Ja.
Irgendetwas Schönes oder
die Situation, die dich so nervt.
(Genervt) Ja.
Schon wieder Probleme
beim Fussball spielen?
Ja, sie schaffen es einfach nicht.
Sie spielen gerne Fussball, aber ...
- Meine schaffen es auch nicht.
C'est la vie! C'est le foot!
Ich werde zwei Mannschaften machen.
Und wenn sie es dann
noch immer nicht schaffen,
wird nicht mehr Fussball gespielt,
denn sie streiten sich immer.
Bei mir gilt die Regel:
Wenn es geht, spielen sie mit,
und wenn sie sich nerven oder
etwas ist, verlassen sie das Spiel.
Bei meinen ist das Problem,
dass sie nicht das Spiel verlassen,
sondern aufeinander losgehen.
Dann gibt es die rote Karte und
eine Spielsperre von einer Woche.
Nur eine Woche?
- Das reicht.
Und danach?
Beginnst du wieder von vorne.
Genau.
Vielleicht mit jemand anderem.
* Lachen *
Ich brauche
diese Art des Austauschs.
Ich brauche Tipps, Unterstützung.
Denn sonst ist es anstrengend.
Ich denke,
die Entwicklung wird so weitergehen.
Es wird immer mehr Kinder geben,
die nicht belastbar sind.
Auch Eltern,
die nicht mehr belastbar sind,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Und wir, das Kollegium ...
Die Ausbildung
wird angepasst werden müssen.
Die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
unterstützen sich gegenseitig.
Der Berufsalltag ist oft
ein Ausprobieren von neuen Ideen.
Dort hat es noch Platz.
Mehmet, für dich auch.
Beispielsweise startet eine Schülerin
von Sandra Maître
mit einer Meditation in den Tag.
Sie geht dafür
in eine andere Klasse.
Das ist auch authentisch, dass wir
meistens schon am Warten sind.
Wir beginnen damit,
uns etwas ruhig zu machen.
Wir wissen, wie das geht -
wir meditieren schon lange zusammen.
Wir suchen uns
eine Sitzposition aus,
in der wir 3 Min. aushalten können.
* Gongschlag *
Du spürst deinen Körper,
ob der ruhig ist.
Deine Füsse, deine Hände.
Du gehst zurück zu deinem Atem
und du bist nicht wütend
oder enttäuscht.
Das ist normal,
die Gedanken tragen dich weg
und du kommst zurück.
Und noch einmal den Atem spüren.
* Gongschlag *
Behalte die Ruhe, öffne die Augen.
Dann gehst du an deinen Platz und
legst dein Mäppchen auf den Tisch.
Ich bewege mich im Kreis und mache
damit alle anderen Kinder unruhig.
Die Meditation macht mich ruhiger,
danach fühle ich mich besser.
Die Kinder lernen so,
sich zu konzentrieren,
es steigert ihre Selbst-
und Impulskontrolle.
Das ist etwas, das in der Schule
ziemlich hilfreich ist.
Auch Sandra Maître und Paula Pfau
versuchen alles,
um Ruhe in ihr Klassenzimmer
zu bringen.
Ich könnte auch ...
Das ist nur eine Idee:
hier einen Vierertisch.
Denn als ich sie fragte,
was sie brauchte, sagte sie:
"Ich brauche viele Freunde.
Ich habe nicht so viele."
Mhm.
- Dass wir so versuchen,
sie im sozialen Umgang zu stärken,
und wenn wir merken,
dass es nicht geht mit Arbeiten,
hat sie die Möglichkeit,
sich zurückzuziehen
und sich dort zu konzentrieren.
Dann müssen wir berücksichtigen,
dass es auch noch andere gibt,
die gerne draussen arbeiten.
Und damit sind wir wieder
beim Thema:
dass es nicht möglich ist,
im Klassenzimmer in Ruhe
und für sich zu arbeiten.
Mhm.
Sie betreiben einen Riesenaufwand,
um sicherzustellen,
dass alle einigermassen
in Ruhe arbeiten können.
Ja, so ist es.
Ich habe inzwischen schon
sechsmal das Zimmer umgestellt.
Damit die Kinder einen Platz haben,
wo sie einigermassen
in Ruhe arbeiten können.
Zudem haben wir Sichtschutzwände
und Kopfhörer angeschafft.
Und die Kinder sagen auch,
dass es zu laut, zu unruhig sei
und sie nicht arbeiten können.
... mal in einen Flow kommt,
dann ist das auch super.
Der administrative Aufwand
habe stark zugenommen:
Sitzungen ausserhalb der Schule,
Gespräche,
Koordination der Fördermassnahmen
und die Elternarbeit
belasten die Lehrerinnen.
Sie können jetzt zusammenpacken
und hier weiterarbeiten,
an den Sternenaufgaben.
Sie?- Ja. In Ordnung?
- Ja.
Sandra Maître schickt jedes Kind in
seine individuelle Fördermassnahme.
Ihr wart im Schwimmunterricht?
- (Kinder) Ja.- Gut.
Zieht bitte schon mal die Schuhe an.
Du kommst bitte rein.
Ich bin gleich wieder bei euch,
ich muss kurz die anderen
in die Logopädie schicken.
Was passiert jetzt genau?
- Sie sind zurück aus der Logopädie
und müssen nun
in die Psychomotorik.
Da es dort ferienbedingt
gerade eine Vertretung gibt,
gehe ich kurz mit,
damit die Kinder nicht meinen,
sie seien am falschen Ort.
Doch zuerst muss ich ...
Sie sind hier.
- Ah.
Jetzt muss ich zuerst
die beiden Kinder holen,
die zur Logopädie müssen.
Da gibt es etwa die Logopädie,
die Begabtenförderung,
die Heilpädagogik
oder wie hier die Psychomotorik.
(Beide) Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hallo, Anessa.
Ihr könnt eure Schuhe
zur Seite stellen.
Wir treffen uns auf der Bank,
wie gewohnt.
Jetzt geht es so:
Du darfst ein Auto aussuchen
und das Auto fährt einmal
über deinen Körper.
Z.B. fährt es an der Hand hoch,
fährt über deine Schulter ...
Ich nehme einen Lamborghini.
- ... über deinen Hals,
da wieder runter
und dort wieder raus.
Jetzt zeige ich dir
meine Autogarage.
Welches Auto findest du gut?
(Genervt) Manno!
- Das hier.
Das hier.
- Du wartest.
Was ist das? Ein Lamborghini?
* Der Junge lacht. *
Stopp!
Du darfst dich flach hinlegen,
die Arme ausbreiten
und den Kopf hinlegen.
- Ist das ein Pfannkuchen?
Und das Auto kommt.
Jetzt ist gut, wenn du ganz leise
bist, weil Anessa spüren muss,
wo das Auto fährt.
- Ich weiss, wo.
Ich mache die erste Runde,
danach können wir abwechseln.
Anessa, das Auto kommt.
- Okay.
Auf dem Fuss.
* Anessa kichert. *
- Kitzelt es?
Tschüss, Porsche.
Es ist eine Übung
zur Körperwahrnehmung.
Die Kinder werden trainiert,
den Fokus zu halten
und sich gezielt
auf einen Punkt zu konzentrieren.
Damit stärken wir auch
die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne.
In dem Moment, wo wir es
wieder aufs Papier bringen,
also sozusagen
vom Körper in den Kopf,
schulen wir die Verbindung
zwischen Körper und Geist.
Das macht die Psychomotorik aus.
Welches Auto wählst du?
Ich will Bumblebee.
Kann ich Bumblebee haben?
Bumblebee?
- Ja.
Okay.
Transformer, mach schon! Roboter!
Dann darfst du dich ganz platt legen
und die Arme strecken. Sehr gut.
Klassenausflug in den Wald.
Paula Pfau und Sandra Maître wollen
eine Woche in der Natur verbringen.
Von dieser Massnahme
erhoffen sie sich
einen positiven Einfluss
auf die Kinder.
Samar, könntest du dich bitte ...
- Okay.
... neben Luca setzen?
- Bitte nicht.
Okay, wir machen nichts mehr,
ich schwöre auf Gott.
Ziel des Ausflugs ist,
dass die Klasse zusammenwächst.
Die Kinder sollen sich in einem
anderen Setting kennenlernen
und v.a. Freundschaften schliessen.
Denn wir haben einige Kinder
in der Klasse, die sagen,
dass sie keine Freund/-innen haben.
Das ist uns auch deshalb wichtig,
weil wir denken,
dass sich das auch
aufs Zusammensein im Klassenzimmer
positiv auswirken und zu einem
stärkeren Miteinander führen kann.
Der Wald als Ort ohne Display
und ohne Reizüberflutung.
* Gesang *
# 23.
# 23, 24, 25, 26.
# 27, 28.
# 29, 30 ...
Jetzt gehen wir hier runter.
Dort gibt es einen schönen Platz
mit Baumstämmen,
wo wir uns hinsetzen können.
Sie haben begonnen,
einen Märchenwald zu bauen.
Daran werden sie heute
weiterarbeiten.
Paula, könntet du bitte kommen?
Wir haben hier eine Krise.
Frust hat sich breitgemacht,
weil alles kaputt ist.
Oh nein!
Über Nacht haben Unbekannte
den selbstgebauten Märchenwald
der Kinder zerstört.
Ich verstehe euch,
ich wäre jetzt auch traurig.
Vielleicht sogar
etwas wütend oder enttäuscht.
Jetzt machen wir es so:
Ihr dürft jetzt zuerst mal
frei spielen.
Und vielleicht kommt euch ja
beim Spielen noch eine gute Idee.
Viel Spass.
- (Junge) Let's go!
* Freudenschreie, Stimmengewirr *
(Seufzend) So ein Mist!
Baustelle.
Mo, Achtung!
- Hol mal das Moos.
* Samar schreit laut. *
Alle weg von Meriam,
sie hat Dreck an den Händen!
* Schrilles Kreischen *
Wie läuft es mit den anderen?
Ein bisschen besser,
weil ich verrückte Freunde habe.
Filmen Sie mal da hinten.
Ja, endlich! Wä!
* Schrei *
Nach dem Austoben zeigt sich ein ganz
anderes Bild als im Klassenzimmer.
Es ist zu eng.
Sie brauchen mehr Raum,
mehr Bewegung.
Wie man nun hier sieht,
können sie still sitzen und zuhören,
was im Klassenzimmer manchmal
ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist.
Ein neuer Tag.
Die Situation im Schulhaus
bleibt angespannt.
Das Lehrerkollegium versucht,
sich weiterhin zu unterstützen,
wo es geht.
Corina Büsch,
Lehrerin einer 4. Klasse,
geht es gleich wie Sandra Maître.
Schwierig, schwierig.
Nichts funktioniert.
Sie sind immer da.
Sie brauchen alles,
was sie nicht erhalten -
keine Therapie,
keine Reaktion von irgendwo.
Ich versuche, was ich kann, aber ...
Aber es gibt einfach einige Kinder,
die nicht in der Lage sind,
etwas aufzunehmen.
Sie sind mit ihren Problemen
beschäftigt,
die tatsächlich auch riesig sind.
Das ist also kein Einzelfall?
Nein. Und wir sehen,
dass es so weitergeht.
Es nimmt sogar eher zu,
auch wenn man die Situation
in den Kindergärten betrachtet.
Es ist schön zu sehen,
dass andere mit den gleichen
Problemen zu kämpfen haben.
Andererseits zeigt es aber auch,
dass wir
ein grösseres Problem haben.
Wenn es nur eine Klasse wäre,
könnte man es lösen.
Aber es ist ein Phänomen,
das sich anscheinend
immer mehr zeigt und zunimmt.
Einige Tage später
kontaktiert mich Corina Büsch.
Sie wolle mir die unerträglichen
Zustände in ihrer Klasse zeigen.
Und tatsächlich wurde kurz darauf
in Lehrerin Büschs Klassenzimmer
randaliert.
An der Wandtafel:
wüste Beleidigungen.
Zugleich ist heute
der Geburtstag von Corina Büsch.
"Du Nutte ..."
Die Kinder finden sich
zwischen Geburtstagsüberraschung
und beschmierter Wandtafel wieder.
Wer hat das gezeichnet?
- Das ist egal.
Parallelklassenlehrerin Corinna Weber
organisiert die Überraschungsparty.
Es ist immer wieder schockierend.
Es sind ganz wenige Kinder,
die so etwas tun.
Man sieht auch, dass die
anderen Kinder schockiert sind.
Aber es trifft einen schon.
Trotz der aufwühlenden Ereignisse Ð
die Überraschung wird nicht abgesagt.
(Kinder)
Happy Birthday, Frau Büsch!
* Knall, Schreie *
So schön!
# Happy birthday to you.
# Happy birthday, liebe Frau Büsch.
Vielen Dank. So schön!
- Bravo.
Das hätte ich nicht erwartet.
Ich schaue mir das an und dann
machen wir hier einen Kreis.
Eigentlich
wollte ich ja unterrichten,
aber das geht jetzt nicht so gut.
Sachen wurden umgeworfen,
meine Sachen bespuckt ...
Es war total chaotisch.
Eklig!
Und ganz schlimme Dinge
wurden an die Tafel geschrieben.
Ich muss jetzt rausfinden,
was da passiert ist.
Wir räumen jetzt etwas auf,
damit wir Unterricht machen können.
Wir können das dann noch
in der Klassenstunde besprechen,
denn jetzt sollten
wir Unterricht machen.
Ja?
- Machen wir jetzt nicht Party?
Nein, jetzt hattet ihr ja
etwas Party.
Ihr konntet etwas knabbern und ...
- Okay.
Für die Lehrerin ist der Vorfall
auch ein Ausdruck der Überforderung.
Was macht das mit Ihnen?
Ich kann das schon einordnen.
Das ist keine Tragödie für mich.
Ich finde, es zeigt einfach, dass
manche Kinder nicht zurechtkommen.
Das Ganze schockiert mich aber
schon auch ein wenig,
wenn ich
an unsere Gesellschaft denke.
Ich nehme es nicht persönlich.
Das habe ich gelernt, sonst wäre ich
im falschen Job. Aber ...
Es schockiert mich,
dass 10-, 11-Jährige -
ich habe selbst
einen Sohn in diesem Alter ...
Ui, also ...
Wenn ich mich zurückerinnere,
als ich in dem Alter war -
es ist schon extrem, wie heute
Grenzen überschritten werden
und wie Kinder
keine Hemmungen mehr haben.
Trotzdem betont sie, wie gerne sie
hier Lehrerin ist und bleibt
und wie sie eigentlich
ein gutes Verhältnis zur Klasse habe.
Das integrative Schulsystem:
für sie eine Knacknuss,
bei dem es noch einiges zu tun gibt.
Dessen ist sich Regierungsrat
Conradin Cramer bewusst.
Er betont, dass man Massnahmen
eingeleitet habe,
wie etwa Lerninseln
oder Fördergruppen.
Der Kanton
will an der Integration festhalten
und dennoch wieder mehr separieren.
Damit eine integrative Schule
gelingt, braucht es auch Separation.
Das gibt es bereits in Basel-Stadt,
und mit den vorgeschlagenen
Massnahmen
gibt es dazu
noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Wichtig dabei ist v.a.,
dass es wieder einen Weg
zurück aus der Separation
in die Regelklasse gibt.
Das ist meiner Meinung nach
ein entscheidender Faktor.
Fürs neue Schuljahr 2024 wurde
das Pensum von Paula Pfau erhöht.
Ihre Kollegin Maître
sieht genau darin die Lösung,
dass bei einer solchen Klasse
die Lehrkräfte doppelt besetzt sind.
Wir sind nach wie vor motiviert
und suchen nach Lösungen.
Wir tauschen uns rege aus
mit anderen Lehrpersonen.
Wir suchen nun einen Weg,
wie wir mit allen 18 Kindern
am besten vorwärtskommen.
Tschüss!
Auf Wiedersehen, Samar.
Auf Wiedersehen, Yannick.
Du machst das gut.
Manchmal ist man einfach müde,
und du hast deinen Traubenzucker
vergessen.
Jetzt aber ...
War's gut?- Mhm.
- Was hast du gemacht?
Wir haben Sudoku gemacht.
Ich habe fünf geschafft.
- Siehst du, super!
Alle Beteiligten
wollen nur das Beste für die Kinder -
nur wie, das ist die grosse Frage.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT